you know your reputation will massively
precede you so
integrity is key treating people like
you would want to be treated if
the shoe is on the other floor that's my
kind of two key things i look for
everything else i think could be teach
how would you describe your first year
in recruitment
a bit of a whirlwind i would say uh i
was obviously
pretty much fresh out of school i had a
couple of
jobs and you know working in top job but
like a call center job before but i'd
never really properly been
in the working world in an office
working you know long hours at the start
it was
definitely a shock to the system and you
know i would be lying if i said in that
first few months i didn't think about
just packing it all in and going back to
topshop about 100 times
um success for me
was initially number one actually
starting to understand what i was
talking about and get my head around the
market
and how um everything kind of slotted
together from a tech point of view
and also it was just
feeling like i was starting to get kind
of
welcomed into the community and other
people who had maybe been doing
recruitment for three years we're asking
my advice on how to engage people on
social media
that gave me you know such a boost